they train you to not put your fingers
on the trigger no no no on top of that
you're never supposed to point it
directly at the soul of someone
everybody did their job correctly or if
just one person did their job correctly
the situation wouldn't happen someone is
responsible and I can't say who that is
but I know it's not me they wanted a cup
[Laughter]
oh okay I'll pay off like it works this
way if you don't pay me I'm wearing the
dynamite vest
it's like extortion that's crazy see
they didn't have budget for Time Crisis
guns we only have budget for real guns
still like the explosion guys walking
with the [__] boss you got to pay
that twenty dollars extra twenty dollars
that's the difference between whether
this set has land mines or not